Speaker 1: I have a story for you today that is
really two stories coming together. Story one
is the story of dishonest Fox News graphics
and charts. Story two is about labor force
conspiracy theories, which we've talked about
before, and the graphic in question here is one
that Fox News put up on the screen yesterday to
try to make Joe Biden look bad, which simply says
the American workforce. Trump peak one
hundred and sixty four million people working
Biden last month only and sixty one
million people working, making the
point that there are 3.1 million fewer people in
the workforce as of last month under Joe Biden
than at the peak during Donald Trump's
administration. Now, I hope that by now,
people who have been watching the show listening
to the show for a while know at least two reasons
why this is so deceptive. But the labor force
stuff is really frequently used by the right to
attack Democrats, so I think it's important
to talk about all of it. So first of all,
without knowing anything about how the labor force
participation rate or labor force participation
numbers are quantified, calculate without knowing
anything at all, you should be suspicious as soon
as you see the Trump peak compared. With last
month, this is called cherry picking of data,
the data for the Trump peak is December of 2019.
They picked that number instead of the number at
the end of Donald Trump's presidency. Why? Well,
because the labor force has grown since Donald
Trump left office. If you compare the end of
Trump's term to right now, you would have to say
the labor force has grown under Joe Biden, so
they pick December of 2019. Now to that end,
why has the labor force been all over the
place? It's been because of the pandemic,
and that's still not over. So even at the top
level, a comparison over the last couple of years
of the labor force participation is of dubious
value. It's a unique it's a different time in
American history because of the pandemic. So yes,
Fox News is being really deceptive. They're cherry
picking. They're leaving out information. Their
viewers are mostly clueless. They see this and
they say, Oh my God, what a disaster Biden has
been. But there is even more instructive stuff
here. The labor participation rate in general
isn't a good indicator of how the economy is
doing, and in fact, in a good economy, the labor
participation rate and the number of people out
of the labor force can go down. Which sir, what?
How is that possible? This is how it's possible.
The labor force participation rate is a measure
of an economy's active workforce. So it's when
we talk about there's one hundred and sixty one
million or one hundred and sixty four million
people in the labor force. We are saying this is
the sum total of all workers employed or seeking
employment. Remember the way it's measured. If
you're unemployed but looking for work, you're
in the labor force. If you stop looking for work,
you're out of the labor force. But if you retire,
you're out of the workforce. If you're 20 and in
college full time, you're out of the workforce
and you reduce the labor participation rate.
So think about that. Really? Think about it?
If you have a bad economy, there are people who
would love to retire, but they can't afford to.
So they need a job, so they get one. The
labor participation rate has just gone up,
but it's because the economy is bad that someone
who would like to be retired has gotten a job.
OK. If the economy is bad, a college student
might have to drop out of school and get a job
to help their family, so the economy being bad has
increased the labor participation rate by forcing
a college student to go and get a job. That's
not a good statistic by itself to tell us how
the economy is doing or whether a president is
doing a good job if wages went up. Now think
about the opposite. Wages went up and the economy
did well. You would see more people say, great,
I can now retire up. Labor participation rate
goes down, but it's because the economy is good.
One last thing, and this is like a systemic
thing about these numbers. The population of
the United States is increasing over time.
It's very common that at any given time,
the number of people working is at a record high
and the number of people not working is also at
a record high. So think about that for a second.
In 2010, the population of the United States was
308 million in 2010. OK, let's just make the
numbers really easy. Forget about the fact that
children aren't considered in the rate. Just
make it 50-50. Three hundred and eight million
people. So in 2010, you could have had one
hundred and fifty four million people working
and one hundred and fifty four million people
not working. We're ignoring kids and people not
counted. So in 2010, you could say breaking record
number of people working and you'd be right.
And at the same time, you could say breaking
record number of people not working and you
would be right. Then we get to 2021. We now have
330 million people in the United States. Make it
50 50. OK, we now have we could have 165 million
people working. That's a record. And 165 million
people not working. That's a record, too. So I
hope that this shows how useless these numbers
can be when the population keeps increasing in
the country anyway. So don't fall for this stuff.
Don't fall for this stuff. Be informed and we'll
have the graphic. If you're just listening today,
we'll put the graphic up on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show